wait i'm doing dracula in atlanta  i mean my god rosenbaum i think i got  between five and ten phone numbers a  night from women what  from playing dracula at the alliance  theater 1300 seats  now  by my powers of most red black  my bonds of blood and i would take  wilhemina and i would pull her right up  to me and i would crawl on her like a  goddamn lizard and there was blood  everywhere and i'm sucking on her and i  we were right at the front of the stage  our heads up no people were screaming  women were losing this [ __ ]  um i had my own coughing i insisted on  you know making sure that we rest at  nighttime  i would go to strip club after strip  club to get the get the whole thing it's  just about the blood it's not about the  body it's about the blood in my head